[Musique]
Oh
qui me dirait il y a longtemps
quand c'était nouveau
qu'entre s'aimer et s'aimer
il y a un secret
et ce n'est pas que je me sens bizarre de cette façon
[Musique]
je ne veux pas dire
pas de honte
C'est juste un cri d'amour que je ne connais pas
s'est terminé là
un univers qui ne revient jamais
ils oublient que je suis tombé amoureux je suis tombé amoureux
Je suis tombé amoureux de t'avoir Je suis tombé amoureux
l'amour c'est étreindre des bombes
[Musique]
je pensais que ce serait peu
tu peux te trouver
[Musique]
et il y a tellement de choses qui font mal et il y a
tellement qu'il laisse
je dis commencer
retomber amoureux
seulement un mystère qui ne finit pas et qui
revient
mais d'amour qui ne s'est pas répété
Je suis tombé amoureux de l'amour
Je suis tombé amoureux de t'avoir Je suis tombé amoureux
tomber amoureux
et je suis tombé amoureux de t'embrasser je suis tombé amoureux
je suis tombé amoureux de toi
amour
[Musique]
et